[Music]  small town girl  [Music]  coca-cola grin  honeysuckle skin  born beneath the ready sign  of a strawberry moon  small town girl  shows up for her friends  crazy bout the bends  i was there when she first  put away childish things  [Music]  we had spring in our heels  [Music]  unwavering forces  head first into the unknown  [Music]  like runaway horses  in a fever till the end  and every step is a silver prayer in the  face of a hard wind  he traded school  put wedding rings in rent  [Music]  small town girl  put your dreams on ice  never thinking twice  some you'll surely forget  some that you never will  [Music]  there was a promise in our stride  but we changed courses  head first into the unknown  [Music]  like runaway horses  in a fever till the end  that every step is a silver prayer in  the face of a hard wind like runaway  horses  it's a long way back home  again  when every step is a silver prayer  in the face of a hard wind  [Music]  [Applause]  so good